actress Shirley Henderson has a career
that spans well beyond a bathroom at
Hogwarts and today we're going to find
out what she's been doing since her
stint in Harry Potter from Korean films
to acclaimed biopics here's what
happened to the actress who played
Moaning Myrtle
when Yuri watch the eight epic Harry
Potter films it probably seems like
every single actor in the United Kingdom
was in the cast including Shirley
Henderson she officially joined the
series in its second outing 2002's Harry
Potter and the Chamber of Secrets as the
ghost known as Moaning Myrtle despite
having roles in previous box-office hits
like the romantic comedy Bridget Jones
diary and director Danny Boyle's
breakthrough film Trainspotting Chamber
of Secrets is the movie that really put
Henderson on the map and in the toilet
Moaning Myrtle
who died at Hogwarts years before Harry
started school still haunts the bathroom
where she died exacting revenge on
school bullies whenever she can find
time to take a break from sobbing
despite her difficult nature she
actually proves useful during her
interactions with Harry in Chamber of
Secrets
Harry eventually discovers that the
mythical monster of Slytherin house is
living in a hidden chamber directly
beneath myrtles bathroom and in Harry
Potter and the Goblet of Fire she
assists Harry as he tries to decipher
one of his tasks for the Triwizard
Tournament even though she does so while
spying on the fourteen-year-old while he
takes a bath perhaps the strangest part
of Hendersons Potter role is that she
was 37 years old when she first played
the ghost of Myrtle immediately after
exiting the Harry Potter franchise in
2005 Shirley Henderson found herself in
a project fit for royalty Sofia Coppola
is avant-garde Marie Antoinette the 2006
film stars Kirsten Dunst as the doomed
Queen of France who enjoys a life of
pure excess before meeting a
particularly grisly end during the
uprisings of the French Revolution the
film which won an Academy Award for best
costume design features Henderson as
Madame Sophie who was frequently at odds
with Marie Antoinette and constantly
plotting against the Queen throughout
her
mein Madame Sophie might not have been a
leading role but it was an important one
proving that Henderson was the perfect
utility player in everything from period
pieces to blockbusters after working on
many successful theatrical releases
Henderson joined the streaming
revolution and took a pivotal role in
Netflix's oak jaw the film is about a
young girl and a super pig whose DNA has
been modified to make it a completely
unique animal and unfortunately a new
food source the talented cast has huge
stars including Tilda Swinton Jake
Gyllenhaal and Paul Dano and of course
their Shirley Henderson in a literal
supporting role as the assistant to
Swinton's Flavie CEO Lucy Miranda
besides being one of Netflix's most
critically praised films the movie gave
Henderson a chance to give a stellar
performance alongside Swinton even
though their characters look like
seriously bad people we don't we don't
Shirley Henderson continued her strong
run in prestigious projects with 28
teens stan and Ollie which stars Oscar
nominee john c reilly as oliver hardy
and steve coogan as Stan Laurel the film
tells the story of the famed comedic duo
as they struggle through personal and
professional problems near the end of
their careers the roles of Laurel and
Hardy's wives required two talented
actresses who wouldn't be diminished to
simple background players stan and Ollie
found that in henderson replaced Lucille
Hardy and Nina Arianda a Broadway star
who plays EDA Laurel the two actresses
brilliantly stand out in the film which
isn't easy next two iconic characters
like Laurel and Hardy such a wonderful
reception isn't it Eden it's okay
to double X for the price of one clearly
Shirley Henderson spent years making a
name for herself in big international
projects but she always found time to
return home and work in highly regarded
British television dramas Henderson
kicked off this trend with 2013's
southcliffe a crime drama where she
portrayed a woman in the midst of a
breakdown working alongside stars like
Game of Thrones Joe Dempsey and black
mirrors Rory Kinnear as inhabitants of a
small town grappling with a series of
violent shootings the show was a huge
success for Henderson earning her a
BAFTA nomination for the role continuing
her pattern of choosing intense
characters Henderson took on a
supporting role in Happy Valley as an
unbalanced woman with a lot of Secrets
and apparently not a single umbrella in
an extremely unexpected reunion
Henderson appeared in Agatha Christie's
the ABC murders with none other than
Rupert Grint her old bathroom buddy from
Harry Potter in the Chamber of Secrets
but even after all these years she still
can't quite get her mind out of the
toilet I prefer my gentleman to not be
Cavalier in their use of the lavatory
paper it blocks out the pipes and then
he's got to get in there with a stick
and break it up plenty of actors jump at
the chance to return to the films that
first brought them attention and Shirley
Henderson is no exception back in 1996
Henderson had some very memorable scenes
in the original Trainspotting and in
2016 she got the chance to reunite with
all of the main cast members for a
sequel Henderson reprised her role as
Gayle who married her boyfriend spud and
had a child with him however when spuds
addiction problems take hold Gail and
her son leave him to figure out his own
recovery
Renton played by you and McGregor tries
to help spud channel his addictive
nature into a more positive direction
with some mixed results eventually spud
gets his act together and helps
financially support Gayle but it's with
stolen money as the film ends it seems
like the two might be heading toward a
lasting reunion although most of
Henderson's scenes are with spud can't
help but think that the actress formerly
known as Moaning Myrtle might have a few
more dirty secrets in common with you
and McGregor check out one of our newest
videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite actresses are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]